يقيل قائد القوات المشتركه وما يتهم الغرب
بالتمسك باوهام خطيره خاسره لتدمير روسيا
الاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين لخفض التوتر واشتباكات بين
الجانبين قربا
[تصفيق]
وزير الخارجيه مصر في دمشق اليوم لتنسيق
تعاون في ملفات عده ابرزها الامن
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
حياكم الله مشاهدينا الكرام اهلا بكم معنا
الى هذه النشره المفصله تاتيكم من العربيه
نبدا ميدانيا من اوكرانيا حيث اعلنت حاله
تاهب في الجو في العاصمه كياف بعد سماع
يدوي في جاره في المدينه في الوقت الذي
يزداد الحديث عن تصعيد روسيا محتمل وفي
اخر المستجدات على الارض ايضا اقال الرئيس
الاوكراني قائد القوه المشتركه الاوكرانيه
ادوارد موسكو من منصبه دون ابداء اسباب
قائد القوات البريه الاوكرانيه العقيد
اوليكساندر سيرسكي تفقد الجبهه في مدينه
بخموت شرق اوكرانيا واعلنت قياده القوات
البريه الاوكرانيه ان الزياره هدفت الى
رفع الروح المعنويه والتحدث عن
الاستراتيجيه مع قاده الوحدات التي تدافع
عن المدينه المحاصره والقرى المحيطه بها
صمود مشاهدينا غير متوقعه للقوات
الاوكرانيه لاثني عشر شهرا ما هو سببه
اولا معنويات مرتفعه لدى العناصر وخليط من
الاسلحه الغربيه ثلاثه من هذه الاسلحه
غيرت مسار الحرب وفقا لتقييم خبراء
عسكريين غربيين وسنتابع سويا ما هي اولها
صواريخ جافلون الامريكيه المضاده للمدرعات
وهي ايضا هذه الجافلين هي منخفضه التكلفه
تسمى بالرمح هي سهله الاستخدام ليلا
ونهارا وتصيب الهدف بسهوله مداه الاقصى
يبلغ
4,750 مترا كما نتابع هنا الصمود
الاوكرانيه ساهمت به ايضا منظومه
المدفعيه وهي عاليه الحركه حيث نتابع هنا
صوره لها هي راجمه صواريخ متعدده منصوبه
على مدرعات خفيفه هذه الراجمه ما هو
خمسه اطنان بامكانها اطلاق ست صواريخ في
الوقت نفسه يتم توجيهها بواسطه نظام تحديد
المواقع الجغرافي ويبلغ مداها نحو 80
كيلومترا كما نتابع قاذفه هايمرس هي سهله
التنقل والحركه ايضا بحيث تطيح للقوات
اصابه الهدف في وقت قياسي والتحرك بعيدا
لتجنب هجمات مضاده كما ساهمت ب 70% من
التقدم العسكري على جبهه خيرسون بحسب قاده
اوكرانيين ما هو السلاح الثالث الذي بنيت
عليه مقدرات الهجوم الاوكراني هي طائرات
بيرقدار وهي طائرات بين اقطار تحديدا تي
بي اثنين وهي مسيرات خفيفه الوزن هي اقل
بحوالي سبع مرات من طائره ريبر الامريكيه
طول جناحيها يبلغ اثني عشره مترا ما يسمح
لها
البقاء في السماء لمده تصل الى 30 ساعه في
الطلعه الواحده هذه الطائرات اثبتت
فعاليتها في اصابه الاهداف حيث يمكن لكل
طائره منها ان تحمل اربعه صواريخ كما
نتابع موجهه بالليزر طبعا من ميزاتها ايضا
القدره على تجميعها من قطع جاهزه
نفت اداره وحرس الحدود البيلاروسي ما ورد
عن وقوع تبادل لاطلاق النار على الحدود
البيلاروسيه الاوكرانيه جاء في البيان انه
لم تكن هناك حوادث وتم استخدام الاسلحه
فيها ولم يفتح حرس الحدود النار وفي وقت
سابق اعلن رئيس قسم التعاون العسكري
الدولي بوزاره الدفاع البيلاروسيه مساعد
وزير الدفاع فاليري ريفينكو ان حلف شمال
الاطلسي قام بتهيئه ظروف لانشاء وحدات
هجوميه في اتجاه بيلاروسيا
قال نائب الرئيس رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي
دمي ان الغرب تتملكه اوهام خطيره وخاسره
بانه عمل على تفكيك الاتحاد السوفيتي
وسيكون قادرا على تصفيه حساباته مع روسيا
وتدميرها دون ان يدفع ثمنا لذلك اكد مدفدى
في مقال النشرات صحيفه
ازبيستيا ان الذي اوصل الى اطلاق العمليه
العسكريه الروسيه في اوكرانيا هي
الهستيريا المجنونه التي تملكت الغرب
ورغبته الجامحه في تمزيق روسيا مشيرا الى
ان تاريخ يثبت ان ايا امبراطوريات انهار
تدفن نصف العالم تحت انقاذها او حتى اكثر
على مشاهدينا نذهب مباشره الى هذه الصور
الحيه والمباشره من فلوريدا وبالتحديد من
حيث تستعد سبيس اكس الشركه المملوكه لرجل
الاعمال الامريكي ايلون ماسك تستعد لارسال
طاقه من رائد الفضاء الى محطه الفضاء
الدوليه في مهمه تستمر لسته اشهر
موجوده
هذه الرحله
هذه الرحله مشاهدينا ستنطلق الساعه
الواحده 45 صباحا بتوقيت شرق الولايات
المتحده من مركز كندي للفضاء التابع
للاداره في كيب كنا بولايه فلوريدا
ايضا مشاهدينا ينضم رائد فضاء اماراتي
واخر روسي الى اثنين من زملائهما في اداره
الطيران والفضاء الامريكيه ناسا
سنكون طبعا مشاهدينا مع عمليه الاطلاق بعد
قليل
لمتابعه طبعا اطلاق شركه سبيس اكس
المملوكه ايلون ماسك طبعا هذه الرحله
الفضائيه والمهمه التي تحمل رواد فضاء من
وكاله ناسا بالاضافه الى رائد فضاء
اماراتي واخر روسي الى المحطه الدوليه في
الفضاء
التقى الرئيس الاوكراني
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه الامير فيصل بن
فرحان في كييف واكد الامير فيصل بن فرحان
لزلنسكي ان المملكه تبذل كل الجهود لتخفيف
معاناه الشعب الاوكراني وقال ان المملكه
قدمت حزمتين من المساعدات لاوكرانيا بقيمه
410 ملايين دولار بدوره شكر الرئيس
الاوكراني المملكه على دعمها لجهود السلام
اكد وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان على حرص المملكه على حل الازمه في
اوكرانيا بالحوار وشدد على ضروره خفض
التصعيد وحمايه المدنيين المملكه حريصه
ايضا
بشكل كبير على
دعم كل ما من شانه اللسان في خفض حده
التوتر والتصعيد والوصول الى حل سلمي لهذه
الحرب ونحن في موقع السعوديه لان الذين
قناع راسخه ان اي نهايه للحرب يجب ان يكون
بالحوار ويجب الكثور على طاوله في اطار
مبادئ القانون الدولي والميثاق للامم
المتحده واحترام سياده الدول ولهذا سوف
نستمر في العمل مع جميع الاطراف للبحث عن
فرص الوصول الى هكذا تسويه
مدير مكتبه الرئيس الاوكراني اندريه
بوزير الخارجيه السعودي اكد ان اوكرانيا
والسعوديه لديهما تحد مشترك بالتعامل مع
المسيرات الايرانيه
اود ان اذكركم بان اوكرانيا والسعوديه
لديهما تحديات وخبرات مشتركه نتحدث عن
مسيرات ايرانيه تم تسليمها لبعض المتمردين
ونفذت هجمات على منشات نفطيه في السعوديه
منذ العام الماضي كانت المسيرات الايرانيه
نفسها في حوزه الارهابيين الروس وتقوم
بهجمات على البنيه التحتيه للطاقه
الاوكرانيه
في الاراضي الفلسطينيه قتل فلسطيني واصيب
اكثر من عشرين اخرين خلال هجوم لمستوطنين
على قريه حواره في نابلس وقد تعرضت نابلس
الى هجوم من المستوطنين والقوات
الاسرائيليه وتمر المستوطنون منازل ومنشات
ومركبات للفلسطينيين ادانت الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه اعمال المستوطنين وقالت انها
تتم بحمايه القوات الاسرائيليه الى ذلك
اتهم زعيم المعارضه الاسرائيليه
لوزير الامن القومي تمار بن جزير اتهمهم
باحراق نابلس من اجل افشال اتفاق العقبه
توعد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيلي نتنياهو
بمطارده منفذ العمليه في الضفه الغربيه
والتي اسفرت عن مقتل مستوطنين اثنين داعيا
المستوطنين الغاضبين الى عدم تطبيق
القانون بايديهم على حد وصفه
وقعت كارثه مروعه اليوم اود ان اتقدم بحر
التعازي لعائله ينيف التي فقدت اثنين من
ابنائه الاعزاء لينتقم الله لدمعهم يقوم
الجيش الاسرائيلي والقوات الامن حاليا
بمطارده القاتل سنجده ونقبض عليه ونتعامل
معه اطلب حتى عندما يكون الدم فائرا
والخواطر هائجه الا تطبق القانون بايديكم
يجب ان يقوم الجيش الاسرائيلي وقوات الامن
بعملهم واذكركم بانهم قضوا في الاسابيع
القليله الماضيه على عشرات الارهابيين
ومنع العشرات من الهجمات الارهابيه دعوا
الجيش الاسرائيلي يكمل مطاردته لا تطبق
القانون بايديكم ومعا سنلزم الارهاب
الاتحاد الاوروبي الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه
عن انزعاجه من اعمال العنف التي اندلعت
بالقرب من حواره بالضفه الغربيه المحتله
واقل الاتحاد الاوروبي في تغريده على
تويتر انه يجب على جميع الاطراف التدخل
بشكل سريع لوقف الاقتتال وحمايه مدنيين
مما يجري في الاراضي الفلسطينيه ومنع سقوط
المزيد من الضحايا
[تصفيق]
نشرتنا مستمره مشاهدينا وفيها بعد قليل
في ايران تجمعات احتجاجيه للمعلمين
المتقاعدين غدا
اهلا بكم من جديد قالت مصادر للعربيه ان
القاهره تعمل على اعاده ترتيب العلاقات مع
سوريا وقد اتخذت قرارا بتوسيع العلاقات
معها اشارت الى ان زياره وزير خارجيه مصر
لدمشق اليوم تهدف لتنسيق التعاون في ملفات
عده واتحدثت المصادر عن ان القاهره
سترسل وفودا الى دمشق لتوسيع قاعده
الزياره بينهما اضافت ايضا ان القاهره
تحاول اقناع واشنطن بتخفيف العقوبات على
سوريا
اعلن المجلس التنسيقي للمنظمات النقابيه
للمعلمين الايرانيين دعمه لدعوه
المتقاعدين اقامه تجمعات احتجاجيه في 28
من فبراير وطلب من المتقاعدين والمعلمين
الحاليين المشاركه في هذه التجمعات افادت
هيئه هيئه صحيه ايرانيه بان اشخاصا قاموا
بتسميم مئات التلميذات في واحده من كبرى
المدن الايرانيه في محاوله لاغلاق مدارس
البنات وكشفت وسائل اعلام محليه عن حالات
تسمم تنافسي لفتيات يناهز عمرهن العشر
سنوات في مدارسكم
تحدى او تحدي يواجه الرئيس التركي رجب طيب
اردوغان لمواجهه تداعيات زلزال السادس من
فبراير لاعاده اعمار البلاد وذلك بالتزامن
مع الوضع الاقتصادي المزري الذي تمر به
تركيا والانتخابات العامه ايضا التي باتت
على الابواب
تداعيات زلزال السادس من فبراير ما تزال
مستمره لتظهر اثارها بشكل واضح على حكومه
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان ومستقبله
السياسي موجها تحديا ايواء اكثر من مليون
ونصف المليون شخص تشردوا بعد ان تهدمت
منازلهم
وعود اطلقها اردوغان لاعاده اعمار البلاد
خلال عام الا ان الضرر طال اكثر من 160
الف مبنى منها
50000 شقه بينما يتوقع الخبراء ان تستغرق
العمليه سنوات عده وان وعود اردوغان تحولت
لتحد خلال الحمله الانتخابيه لحزبه المقبل
على الانتخابات العامه في مايو المقبل
اضرار ماديه وصلت قيمتها الى 25 مليار
دولار في تركيا بحسب بنك جي بي مورجان
الامريكي ستتحملها الحكومه التركيه
وتقديرات اخرى تشير الى اكثر من ذلك الرقم
لتكون المساعدات الدوليه التي تقدمها
الدول والبنوك والمنظمات العالميه هي
المصدر الحالي الوحيد لتمويل خطه اعاده
الاعمار
كارثه الزلزال سبقها زلزال اقتصادي اذ
يتجاوز حجم التضخم الحالي في تركيا
57% والذي يسوء وضعه بعد تعطل المعامل
والشركات وايقاف التداول في البورصه
التركيه
اطلعت رايا تشير الى تراجع شعبيه حزب
العداله والتنميه في المناطق المنكوبه
واصوات شعبيه غاضبه تعلو اصوات الناخبين
بسبب بطء الحكومه لارسال فرق الانقاذ وعدم
الاستجابه الفوريه في بعض المناطق
يتزامن كل ذلك مع القاء اللائمه على
قوانين البناء والمقاولين والتي ساهمت
بارتفاع عدد الضحايا عمر العربيه
اعلنت بريطانيا عفوا اذا اعلنت بريطانيا
مشاهدينا رئيس وزرائها
سيلتقي اليوم الاثنين في لندن رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه
وذلك للاعلان عن التفاصيل تعديلات التي
ادخلت على بروتوكول ايرلندا الشماليه
والخاص بخروج المملكه المتحده من الاتحاد
الاوروبي اكدت رئاسه الوزراء البريطانيه
في بياننا ان سوناك وافواندر ليان اتفقا
على اتمام العمل باللقاء شخصيا في لندن من
اجل التوصل الى تسويه عمليه او تسويه
عمليه ومتفق عليها لتجاوز التحديات
المعقده حول البروتوكول ووضع ايرلندا
الشماليه بشكل عام
طلبات منظمه الصحه العالميه جامعه 392
مليون دولار قبل مؤتمر للماني حين تنظمه
الامم المتحده وسويسرا والسويد في جناف
ليجنب انهيار محتمل قطاع الصحه في اليمن
واقلت المنظمه ان التمويل الجديد مطلوب
لضمان استمرار المرافق الصحيه في تقديم
الخدمات لنحو 13 مليون شخص من بينهم 540
الف طفل دون سن الخامسه يعانون سوء
التغذيه او سوء التغذيه الحاد مع خطر او
خطر مباشر للوفاه
تعيش عشرات الاسر النازحه من منطقه الرحبه
في الريف الغربي لتعز وضع النسويا صعبا
بعد ان هجرتهم الميليشيات الحوثيه من
منازلهم في منطقه تطوير غربي تعز
ليسوا كباقي نازحي البلده لقد عاشوا
التشرد مرتين مرتين حين هجرتهم الميليشيات
الحوثيه من ديارهم في الطوير الغربي تعز
والاخرى حين اقر مالكو هذه المساحه اقتلاع
مخيماتهم لاخلاء سبيل الارض التي كانوا
يعيشون فيها فتره النزوح
حصل حرب علينا احنا كان القضايا
الثقبيوتنا رحت الطبيوتنا فقاعه وجهاله
نحن رجحنا نجحنا من الطور للرحبه الرحبه
حوالي فتره قليل وقاموا
رجعنا قالوا
تعامل مؤلم يقولون اشعرهم بالغربه في
بلدهم بل ودفع بهم الى ارض قاحله تتوسط
جبلين في الرحبه غربا نساء واطفال يصطفون
هنا بحثا عن مياه الشرب فقط وشيوخ عاجزون
عن الحركه يجسدون حقيقه الماساه لاكثر من
700 شخص في المخيم هذا
ولا سكر ولا هذاك ولا معانا اي حاجه يسكن
هذا المخيم اكثر من
173 اسره داخل المخيم من غير ساكنين
المنازل وعدد الافراد 7 اكثر من 771 فرد
يعانون من سته المعاناه في هذا المخيم
فالماء يقلبوه مسافات ثلاثه كيلو لجوء
اضطراري لمئات النازحين في المخيم الى قطع
مسافات كبيره لجلب المياه والغذاء والدواء
من مناطق بعيده عن المكان الذي نصبوا عليه
المخيمات فالمواد الغذائيه لا تاتيهم
بانتظام من المنظمات الاغاثيه يقولون اما
المواد الايوائيه فباتت شبهها معدومه
هكذا اذا وبوضع ماساوي تعيش عشرات الاسر
النازحه في المخيم هذا ضنك الحياه منذ ان
هجرتهم الميليشيات الحوثيه من منازلهم في
الطوير الغربي المدينه فالحصول على ما يسد
الرمق بالنسبه لهم اهم من تحقيق حلم
العوده الى الديار هل سعيد العربيه من
مخيم الرحبه غربي مدينه تعز
تونسيه وضع حدا لتدفق اعداد كبيره من
المهاجرين غير النظاميين من افريقيا جنوب
الصحراء على تونس اثار ردود فعل متباينه
بين داعم لها وبين من وصفها بالخطيره
والعنصريه فيما اكد الرئيس قيس سعيد بان
الخطوه جاءت تطبيقا للقانون ولحمايه الامن
القومي التونسي دون المسب الافارقه
الموجودين في البلاد بشكل قانوني
في محطه لغسيل السيارات باحد الاحياء
الشعبيه في تونس العاصمه منذ سنه 15 و20
يقول انه غير معني باثاره موضوع وجود
الافارقه من جنوب الصحراء في البلاد طالما
انه ملتزم بالقانون
علينا ان نقبل بوضعيتنا هنا علينا ان نعمل
فقط حتى نعيش بكرامه يجب ان نلتزم
بالقوانين
وضعيه درمان ليست كغيره من الاف الافارقه
الذين اثار وجودهم في البلاد اشكالا
للسلطات التونسيه حاولنا الاتصال برئيس
الجاليات الافريقيه لكنه اعتذر خوفا من
تهديدات قد تطاله في ظل الحديث عن
استهدافهم وترحيلهم رغم تاكيد السلطات
التونسيه ان المساله تتعلق بتطبيق القانون
فقط
طالبنا بتطبيق القانون ولكن ليطمئن
الافارقه الموجودون في تونس بصفه قانونيه
على اوضاعهم
وترتبط مساله وجود الاف الافارقه في تونس
بقضيه الهجره حيث امضت الدوله التونسيه
اتفاقيات في الغرض مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
منذ تسعينات القرن الماضي الهدف منها
دائما وهاتي الاتفاقيات هو الحد من وصول
المهاجرين غير النظامين الى بلدان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سواء كان تونسيين او اجانب
منطلقين من تونس وتعمل السلطات التونسيه
مؤخرا على حمايه حدودها البريه والبحريه
للحد من تدفق المهاجرين غير النظاميين
عليها
بين تعقيدات الوضع القانوني والامنيه من
جهه ومساله حقوق الانسان من جهه اخرى يبدو
الحل لوضعيه الافارقه من جنوب الصحراء في
تونس صعبا في ظل ارتباطه بمساله الهجره
غير نظاميه التي تؤرق السلطات في ضفه
البحر الابيض المتوسط وليد عبد الله
العربيه
تونس
تواصل قوه خفر السواحل الايطاليه البحث عن
مفقودين بعد ان تحطم زورق لمهاجرين قرابه
الساحل الجنوبي لايطاليا قضى فيه نحو 60
شخصا اثناء محاولتهم التوجه الى اوروبا
الى العناوين
زيلينسكي يقيل قائد القوات المشتركه ومداد
يتهم الغرب بالتمسك باوهام خطيره خاسره
لتدمير روسيا
والاتحاد الاوروبي يدعو الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين
قرب نابلس
وزير خارجيه مصر في دمشق اليوم لتنسيق
تعاون في ملفات عده ابرزها الامن
دائما مشاهدينا العربيه
والقاكم بعد دقائق معدودات في نشره اخرى
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]